Speaker 1: So there's a very sinister new
character that now is becoming a prominent
player in right wing media, and it is really
reminiscent of Soviet era propaganda, not only
in substance but also kind of in appearance.
And you'll see what I mean in a moment. Some
relatively short period of time ago, Donald Trump
hired a new spokeswoman, and that spokeswoman
is a woman named Liz Harrington. And I'm
going to play a couple of clips of her,
from the media, from the last couple of days.
And it is not only what comes out of her mouth
mouth that is sort of out and out Soviet style
propaganda. Even the appearance is weird. We're
like, it's not clear if it's a green screen or
what's going on. But even like her skin tone and
the production value is reminiscent of like Cold
War era propaganda and or hostage type videos.
And it's it's all very, very crazy. So let's
take a look at this first clip. This is from Real
America's Voice The War Room with, I guess, Steve
Bannon. I don't know. Let's take a look at this,
and you know, this could be straight
out of of of the Soviet era Russia,
Speaker 2: the one they can try to read as many
Donald J. Trump supporters as they want. We're
just going to keep coming. We're going to
keep pressing for. We're going to get the
truth about the election and everyone will
believe it. Everyone already knows that this
election was wrong, that something was not right.
Speaker 1: It is 15 months since the election.
She's talking about 15 months. And much like we
we've seen in propaganda movements elsewhere,
you know, North Korea insists Kim Jong Il really
got a hole in one on every hole the first time he
played golf and controls rainbows. And,
you know, all the different stuff, and
nobody believes it. But at the same time,
everybody sort of pretends to believe it and
they keep repeating it and you have to go along.
Similar to the things we hear out of Russia,
similar to things we've heard, you know, all sorts
of different places. And the production value
is like a cross between Soviet propaganda videos
and old 90's video games. I used to play like Duke
Nukem 3D. I mean, it's all just strange. But 15
months later, folks, they are saying the evidence
is coming any day now we're going to get the
evidence. Here's another clip also. Again, I don't
know if it's a poorly lit green screen or what it
is, but the appear she looks like she's being held
hostage. And here's a longer propaganda clip.
Speaker 3: You know, there's I think,
one of the reasons a lot of our colleagues
in the old media don't want to talk about it
is they know he is going to be a force to jaw in
the next election. I recently saw the letter that
Governor Youngkin sent the president thanking
for his help in getting elected in Virginia.
That's something that the mainstream media doesn't
want to talk about. But tell us about how Donald
Trump is going to play a role in the twenty two
twenty twenty elections. As Kevin McCarthy and
troops try to take the House and the Senate.
Speaker 2: Well, the power of the endorsement.
That's another thing that is ignored by the
fake news, but it's not ignored in the world
of politics. I can tell you everyone wants the
Trump endorsement. They're always hounding us
for that ever important endorsement because
they know it will put them over the finish line.
Speaker 1: So now it's not really true that
Trump's record is so good. I mean, in the
2018 midterms to go back to a midterm, Trump
endorsed 75 candidates, and about half of them won
55 percent one. It's not that good, particularly
when you consider the power of incumbency and a
bias to success when you're endorsing incumbents.
During Trump's entire presidency 2017 to 2021,
ballot pedia tracked 305 Trump endorsements,
and then when he left office, he made another 49
endorsements, so it's 354 total. His record was
77 percent won. And again, there's a major bias
to success because he mostly was endorsing
incumbents and incumbents usually win. So
his record really isn't that
good, but it doesn't matter.
They have now gone fully in this. You can't
believe what anybody tells you. You can't
believe what you see. You can't believe what you
hear. You can't even believe what you believe
to be evidence even that you have to doubt. You
have to believe. What Liz Harrington tells you
from her bizarre, bizarrely lit, extremely
weird screen that that she's coming to you from
and this is likely going to continue and if and
until, you know, yesterday we talked about the
whole Rogen thing, Rogen saying, people aren't
smart if they listen to me for vaccine advice.
And much the same way the people that are
watching this stuff are people who don't
have the critical thinking skills. They don't
have the media literacy wherewithal to question
the messages and the things that they are being
told. And so in all likelihood, they're going
to continue believing it and the impacts of that
are certainly going to be felt in the midterms.